good evening and welcome to the planning
committee West in the absence of the
chairman and vice-chairman we need to
appoint a chairman for the meeting can I
ask for nominations please I'd like to
propose counts to Cargill
mr. chairman thank you could just
confirm all those in favor thank you
welcome everybody welcome to West area
planning on mark column I'll be showing
the meeting this evening right agenda
apologies for absence from Katz
Watkinson for whom councillor Kendall is
substituting councillor courage for him
councillor Perry is substituting counsel
Charles for whom councillor fielding is
substituting counsel Lawton council pain
for him counts the brain is substituting
counselor Vaudrey and councillor
richards for him counselor Cargill is
substituting thank you members are there
any declarations of interest that's
certainly interesting thank you all
right minutes yes sorry chairman my any
declarations of interest are four wells
one campus and Kings meat farm for which
I'm the county councillor representing
that district but I can't see the impact
on my decision-making
okay thank you
members thank you right I'm going to get
the officers to introduce themselves
starting from my right Caroline Mashka
the administrator Ross chambers legal
services my name is David Jeffrey I am
the Western team leader in my role as an
impartial adviser to the committee I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
doing so I am bound by the code of
conduct of the Royal Town Planning
Institute planning committee members are
not bound by case offices recommendation
or by all advice Eddie wrench senior
planning officer
we flee it's planning officer thank you
everybody
there are no fire alarm scheduled for
this evening is event Aliso if you do
hear one please make your way outside
and meet in the carpark by the side of
the the bindle Club right I shall start
the meeting them the first item on the
agenda this evening is application 18/2
below 9 4 o / out David which one to
just explain or something here I am
going to ask for Caroline's suggestion
to further minutes until the next
meeting okay
Thank You chair in respective
application 18 / 0 0 9 4 0 / out
veterinary investigation center in
Ludington in accordance with the
provisions of the new constitution we
propose that that item be delegated
Thank You members the vote is to
withdraw to delegate that to officers
recommendations all those other proposal
a second day you count the bars council
fielding all those in favor as unanimous
thank you okay
application 1918 SPAD double o 9 4 o /
out has been deferred for delegation to
the offices Oh incidentally and I don't
do this very often if men after the the
members on the table would like to take
their ties off they're more than welcome
to this evening you wouldn't hear me say
that very often there you go more than
welcome to take attire
thank you and I'm not going to move on
to application 18 / go 1 2 6 7 fall
Wells on campus Wells Moorpark David
would you like to explain please
Thank You Jay in respect of this
application where the Parish Council has
chosen not to attend and there are no
other speakers in respect of the
proposal in accordance with the new
provisions of the Constitution we
propose to delegate that in accordance
with officers recommendation Thank You
members the vote before you is to
delegate the application 18 / 0 1 2 6 7
stars fall cover poseur for that cancer
brain second there can have a second to
please so you came to the pass
all those in favor thank you right let's
move now on to the application 17 such a
3 5 9 5 / 4 5 shreaves orc Stockton on
Aven and the presenting officer is Amy
Thank You chairman the application sites
which is donated by the black dot in the
center of the plan is located within the
town centre and built-up area boundary
of stratford-upon-avon the site edge
Dredd comprises a commercial unit within
Treves walk a courtyard retail
development of sheep Street there are a
number of listed buildings surrounding
the site and the site is also within the
conservation area an aerial image shows
the parking surface air a parking
service area is situated to the north of
Shrieves walk and sheep street is
situated to the south for planning
permission is sought for the change of
use of the unit from a one shop to a for
drinking establishment the application
does not propose alterations to the shop
front so this photo is taken looking
towards Reeves walk where the unit is
located at the access there is a pair of
existing gates so this photo is taken
within trees walk looking south towards
sheep Street Shrieves house is the
nearest residential dwelling which can
be seen in the top right corner of the
screen now this image shows that the
proposed unit which is seeking to you
obviously have it use change from a1 to
a4 and this photo is taking looking
north of the unit where shreves walk
becomes covered leading towards the
parking service area to the rear and
finally this image is taken from the
parking service area looking towards
Reeves walk and again at the access
there are some gates which are existing
and chairman subject to the prior
satisfactory completion of a section 106
agreement it is recommended to grant
permission subject to the conditions as
detailed within the committee report
thank you right our first speaker or
speakers as mr. flowers and John Ford if
you'd like to come forward thank you
either did wherever you know we're easy
to sit it's up to you yeah by all means
and you have three
it's in your own time thank you and
they'll make a suggestion that you pull
them microphone down a little bit but
don't speak too closely into it other
big becomes distorted okay and press the
button the bottom okay okay thank you
for the opportunity to speak at this
meeting the following statement has been
signed and agreed by a number of
businesses of Occupy or adjacent to
Sherry's walk there are two main areas
of concern antisocial behavior and
access to the premise in case of an
emergency the alkalis alcohol license
that was granted by Stratford upon over
district council on the 15th of March
stipulates amongst other things that the
rear access gates must remain locked
after 7:00 p.m. the planning application
states an anticipated maximum of 40
persons will be allowed in the premises
however plan shows there is only one
toilet available this together with the
lock gates and the dogleg like passage
leading to these gates will encourage
all sorts of anti-social behavior and
undesirable activity not to mention the
noise and disruption created during open
hours with with the speech of customers
into the narrow public walkway this all
disrupts the quiet enjoyment of the
occupants at Reeves house adjacency
frees house shade walk is shri house a
great two stylistic building of
historical significance it attained this
particular business is also home of the
prior proprietors they have raised
concerns relating to security and carers
of Sai customers outside of the premises
we have already evidence Missa beans
being satellites by careless smokers
therefore we would urge all of the bins
be removed the fire service submitted
their replies to the panel meditation on
the 5th of February 2018 in their reply
under the heading for consideration may
states Warwickshire Fire and Rescue
sorta thority askew
SDC to consider ensure the access to the
site during construction and once
completed it means maintaining it free
from obstructions this is not possible
if the rear gates at a service area
are locked I would emphasize the SC DC's
instructions to lock the gates was made
before grant and was made in granting of
the license on the 15th of March 2018
this was after the 5th of February
response from fire service my question
is was the fire service response taken
into consideration when making the
decision for the license and has the
fire service had the opportunity to
officially response that a license
stipulation of locking the gates as they
would not have had prior knowledge of
this thank you thank you very much if
you want to wait a moment just in case
there any questions members do you have
any questions
Caspari good evening just wondered
whether you can confirm the operating
times of the businesses that are
operating in do they then currently
closed before 7 p.m. in things they turn
most are closed by 5:30 6 o'clock
question you mentioned that some of the
bins been set on fire indeed there have
been instances where so sorry ok there
have been instances where people have
carelessly stops cigarettes out put them
in the beam and later on there has they
have caught fire people have had to put
them out I'm making assumption then that
that was during the day yeah that was
queuing dying so your your
representation is to actually have the
bins removed the external pins indeed
yes ok thank you
[Music]
most most are clothes plus the latest
they normally open you seven o'clock but
most are closed by 5:30 Gaza fielding
basically it was going to be the same
question I was just wondering whether
there are any food retailers in in that
area not now there are not okay thank
you no not in truth walk a lot and close
down a few weeks ago there any other
questions you'd like to ask thank you
thank you if you could press a button on
the bottom please I'd appreciate it
thank you very much indeed thank you
alright our next applicant is ill with
us killing mr. with us again you have
three minutes to say what you wish to
the but button at the bottom of the
microphone there to turn the red light
on as I said don't get too close to the
microphone as it gets distorted okay
thank you okay perfect first if I could
tell you a little bit about the brand it
is a high-end gin and Prosecco bar where
you will buy drinks in the same where do
you buy food via taste profiles or you
wouldn't buy by a brand you could if you
wanted to of course the aim is to give
people an experience so about the
experience
the maximum number we talk about is
probably 40 but would ultimately
probably a little bit less certainly
inside because of space woman that was a
plan there earlier but it's about
they're not marking juniper Sekhar bar
it's not about style of myself in shape
which if you look around the area that
we're looking at opposite directly
opposite there's a the Rosen crown and
the other side is Weatherspoon's which
would hold ten fold of the number that
we talked met here and their profile is
to stack attire sand it cheap and the
activity we've talked about it's more
likely to happen there which already
have one that are nice and seasoned and
are controlling it and then it's
happening our establishment where it
the quality not about the quantity our
target audience would be post theatre
post dinner where if you wanted to you
may choose that to go and have a drink a
quality drink serve really well and a
great choice and serve dinner in the
right environment again not about having
lots of drink but getting the right
drink served in the right way the way
that the person who designed the drink
intended to be drunk as I mentioned
they're all in local operators like
Weatherspoon's
and there are some Craven who have
licenses that are till 1:00 in the
morning
very close to this all OD in this area
and they have learned to cope with the
tome of traffic and all the hues that
social behavior bring in addition of an
operator myself I already have
Stratford's only dancing nightclub that
is number one Shakespeare Street in the
heart of residency and since I've been
there two years you if you check any
record you'll say that all the
anti-social behavior has gone down we
have very few complaints if any very few
fighting very few any of the things that
people would be a frightened of and I
get the fear
I understand the fear if you don't know
what it is you're looking at the new you
are fearful of it to help all these
things we've as mentioned with the 106
degree move a great for CCTV to be
operation and also I mean that's quite a
small place we've agreed that we open
after midnight we'll have no security
there for nine o'clock which means that
some of the things that you're talking
about there's somebody there
specifically to manage that's 30 seconds
please okay man exactly I said I'm a
loss and say already in Stratford up an
island so you know I know what will that
means and I've operated last two years
in the town centre and we know how to
operate it in the town centre we could
at what we do and the evidence is there
for boys to see these a lot more cyber I
know a lot of times I'm afraid you two
you have or another time thank you very
much do you see where this
right before we go open it up to the
other members you say 40 people maximum
but that would be inside and you know
are there any outside spaces of your own
envisaging outside of I lost authority
to serve drinks to be consumed I'm not
the premises so we could serve drinks
outside should we choose to and that'll
depend on the weather and also how we we
set the business up but this is a new
venture a new style for the both of us
and in this town and we don't know how
it's gonna help it will use it and often
things have dictated to how the people
you to choose it and suppose that we
think it's going to be used okay thank
you okay
just remembers reference I haven't think
this limited to ten people outside yes
the indications are that this has been
opened in in other areas is there an
example of where else this has been this
type of facility it's being used it's
not by us but it's more and more popular
if you look at the profile of gin if the
graph of gin has been huge and as most
people know in the last few years so I
could point you to lots of gin bars the
most popular in this area would be
number forty sinful square in Birmingham
which is of a similar size and use the
same style of selling Jim buy the
profile by the flavor profile so that
does exist as 1440 simple square yes
Calipari thank you chair
I wonder whether you could just give us
an indication of what your plans are in
terms of music venue the music sold is
really just designed to be background
music no more there might be honest
after day night at 7 o'clock we'll have
a Giro playing it's a very small space
it would never be any more than that
because he just he put a band in there
they couldn't get the people in there so
common sense would prevail a building
single person or a do it at the very
director their very very best never any
more than that and background music it's
a most steep like this is about the
experience and the experience is the way
that you
and drink a quality product loud music
doesn't go with that drinking to the
excess doesn't go with that being sick
climbing walls doing all the things that
people fear and I understand the fear
just doesn't go with the brand and if we
that happened once we've got it very
very wrong and we would look to do
something very quickly about it it
wouldn't work for us thank you of course
when the stipulations put to us was that
the back gates are the north gate it
does is channel is a dogleg so we're in
the way of the streams walk straight
walk which is the front end that keep
straight he goes down there into a
dogleg and then out towards the car park
at that point where leaves trees walk
there is a gate so on a keypad so what
currently happens back in front the last
person who thinks they are leaving
closes the gates as a keeper on there so
should you be caught inside or one thing
at back you put your key card in open
the door and then you go it's been
stipulated but to us that would like the
back door locked
so we've agreed by the 106 agreement
which will be coming to play should we
get everything granted that camera would
face down towards the locked gate in the
dogleg and down towards shrevie Street
so all the angles will be covered off so
from inside the venue we could see all
of the corners and again as I said
before one of the things we agree these
twelve o'clock without doormen from nine
o'clock so I'm from nine o'clock that
betraying people there as I tried people
and my business partner is somebody who
trains the people to do these things to
one to the cameras and watch the walkway
that would
now if we're open past 12 we have to
have a doorman from nine so we're asking
for a one o'clock license if we were to
open to 11 there's no requirement Abdur
self if we open past 12 there's a
requirement of dorsa from 9 thank you I
just wonder whether you there is in
within the committee report as a
recommendation from the environmental
team that closures should be at 23 hours
could you just give your thoughts on
that because you've mentioned going past
12 o'clock and you've also mentioned 1
a.m. whereas we have a recommendation
within the committee report from the
Environmental Health Team that closure
should be at 23 absolutely
first of all we've satisfied the license
conditions all of them so we're for the
loss and was granted to 1:00 in the
morning and the brand itself the idea is
that if you go to the theater or have
dinner until 10:30 core to 11:00
you should then be able to come and have
a drink in the right place of the things
that you'd want to do 11 o'clock if you
look all around the town center and any
way you would go to have a drink we feel
is just too early because 11 o'clock you
would just require theater at half past
and quarter to 11:00 what time you
walked it would be too late then we can
see no logical reason why 11 o'clock
should be the cutoff time when habits
are changing and people would expect to
have a drink post 11 o'clock in most
places these days it's it's the room is
a similar size to my lounge in kitchen
it is a very small room you can't see it
from the plan but you couldn't before
music in there and have the right
environment
members are any other questions of mr.
withers if not thank you very much
indeed just press the button on the
bottom of the microphone thank you very
much
count so freshly okay the bar itself
sounds delightful I just think it's in
the wrong place
my real concerns here are about to jump
did the geography of the area where this
per second bar wishes to locate I think
it's fought with difficulties the bar is
situated in this pretty shopping lane
accessed from sheeps route by gates
presently locked around about six seven
o'clock by the last business to leave
the lane goes through to the slaughter
yard via a dogleg which leads into a
rather dark area and the gate here will
be locked from seven o'clock onwards and
according to the licensing agreement no
activity that that door has that gate
has to be locked while there is licensed
animal activities taking place in that
area to my mind this is incompatible
with the safety of the customers if
there was a far-our customers could run
to the right if they did run to the
right there'd be round the dogleg and up
against locked doors if there was any
kind of disturbance which can happen and
people actually ran to the right they
would once more be around that dogleg
and against a locked door and that could
be extremely dangerous so it's the
geography that is of real concern here
as mentioned by the resident I
understand that fire service were
unaware that this gate was being locked
at night when they gave their view ten
people are allowed to be outside the
premises before 11 o'clock at night
that's a quarter of the customers of the
maximum number of customers the nature
of this area will attract more
and stipulated 40 because of the layout
becomes difficult to monitor people can
actually enter through from from sheep
Street through the open gates there
perhaps wander pass the closed doors and
into the dogleg the dark area at the
back I'm not sure where the sees I'm
sorry I'm not sure what the CCTV cameras
will be because it does say in the
licensing that they are only licensed
premises the dodgy area is actually
around this dogleg which goes through a
locked door and I'm not sure if the CCTV
cameras will actually go into that space
I know comments on the page on the
planning portal suggests that this would
be an ideal venue to go after the
purpose of shut from the description
you've had this is not an ideal place
for people after the purpose of shot but
it will be open until one o'clock on
Fridays and Saturdays so you could have
that scenario of people turning up
they're already fairly jolly and
actually destroying the atmosphere
that's been described and causing some
of the anti-social behavior which is
very much feared by the people and the
businesses that operate there has been
said the premises are quite small
because there's so many tables and
chairs and sofas in there the two dogs
at the back seemed to open one to the
the toilet area and the story they're
opening out into the space taking away
space by people could stand and the bar
does seem quite small to service such a
large area I'm not sure if the loo is
DDA compliant and I understand that
there are steps to get up into the
premise which don't have a deep do sort
of disabled access I know that the
police are concerned that the compliant
CCTV family should be in place before
the premises Oh
which suggests some concern of their
part and as I've said I'm not sure
exactly where they CCTV cameras are
actually going to be placed to make sure
that behavior is properly controlled I'm
not sure over the 40 people that were
allowed in whether the star fall on top
of that or whether it's 40 customers so
it could be a few more people actually
using the small space concerned about
the 10 people being outside up until 11
o'clock very high brick walls here which
will amplify and bounce the noise alone
at about 30 seconds please and as I say
coming back to my original point
it's a secluded geography of this area
which I have real concerns about and
whether there's going to be sufficient
dual keeping to make sure that area is
going to be safe and the numbers are
going to be restricted to two to the 40
thank you
Thank You cousin I'm just a comment
really and see what your particular
viewers on this at the moment there are
two pubs adjacent to this unit both of
which correct me if I'm wrong
are open until one o'clock at the
weekends so what would be the difference
in this particular context with this
particular bar you've got an alleyway
and then you've got this dogleg you've
got gates at both ends it doesn't have
an access onto an open access onto the
street so you've got the premise you
will have access to that premise to the
gates from sheep Street if you continued
along there you would go past the dogleg
into a very dark space and there the
door is locked the gate is locked so you
cannot get into this close to you I will
be asking the officer about that
especially in the picture of that yes I
will be asking the officer about that
because of the comments from the Fire
Rescue Service will we come
that particular point in the moment okay
okay thank you members any other
questions that council friendly yes
which has a thriving nighttime economy
what would you see the difference
between this and those that work very
well apart from the games the noise the
noise element though because it is quite
a constricted area and we have had
complaints from other venues in the town
where you actually have people but my
main concern is the safety with the
logged gates other premises are don't
have the same sort of log gates
okay thank you okay thank you for answer
all right members um technical questions
of the other side I'm going to ask the
first one because I mean I'm in charge
here so that's it right the first one
then is the Amy can you cut points here
one is obviously the lot of the gates
and is there anything now that we need
to reconsider considering the report
from the Fire Rescue Service and the
other one is the CCTV and now obviously
at the moment we are assuming that the
gate is closed but it may be if that
gate I'm not putting words in your mouth
is to be open because the Fire Rescue
Service recommendations would the CCTV
coverage need to be changed to cover
that particular area please
so as we were standing a condition of
the licensing is that the gate should be
shot from the seven o'clock
Thank You members Casa fielding
how many thought being given to putting
typical sort of fard or arrangement on
that door so that people coming from the
square can actually in emergency can
open the door and probably spring-loaded
so it will then close behind them as I
say that the expectations and of the
fire and rescue Authority is that the
approve development would meet with
building regs document be volume to
section b5 which deals with access and
facilities for the fire service and they
also endorse the support of sprinklers
and other measures in accordance with
British standards those matters would
come through building regulations
principally where would the spring
sprinklers be in the in the actual
facility or because what I'm referring
to is the the door at the far end having
a typical type of emergency door opening
and closing which you can use after the
doors have been shut at seven o'clock
yeah I think there's no details of some
answer about the planning provision
previously he implied that it in the
planning it was finishing at seven
o'clock I think the confusion was that
currently the gates are closed at seven
o'clock
currently yes so planning permission
that we're approving
goes the same as the license well there
is a recommendation that is slightly
different from the one of the licensing
application but we can have a chat about
that so I would like to raise that more
with the officer in a moment if that's
okay with you counsel brain also it
counts a penny first I apologize cares
about me
Thank You chair I just wonder whether
the officers can clarify if the fire
service was fully aware that the gate
the ech one of the exit gates was going
to be closed at the point of
consultation the fire authority would
have had all the information available
on the planning application the
licensing agreement obviously came in
advance of the planning application
whether they give gave that particular
element of detail consideration it's not
clear from council brain
chairman I just want to be clear on page
30 the adviser of the environmental
health officers recommendation as we
know for 2300 hours I understood I heard
the applicants say he's got to one
o'clock that would have gone through the
licensing panel is that correct no just
want to clarify that before we went any
further I agree and that is a
clarification on just going to rave with
the officer now asking me but we can ask
the officer now is that why have we
decided or proposing that any different
time be allocated as opposed to the
licensing conditions so the licensing
panel and the application for a license
deals principally with issues of
nuisance and the prevention thereof the
planning application procedure and our
adopted core strategy encompasses a
range of amenity matters that go beyond
just pure nuisance we did consult with
environmental health and the 11 o'clock
closing time was proposed by them in
their correspondence with us taking all
of that into account with the details we
had on the application we thought that
the 11 o'clock closing time strikes the
right balance between protecting the
immunity of nearby residents and other
users and promoting an iconic nighttime
economy they can I just pick up on that
particular point please for the
licensing application was that
environmental health advice given I'm
not to interrupt but we've had one of
the four all's we're and printable
people opposed the license going on so
environmental health spent two hours
before the licensing went through to
agree the new conditions
there now I'm wondering whether this has
been done conditions otherwise I would
be happy to defer it same subject really
I'm wondering if this advice from the
Environmental Health Officer is the same
advice that went to the licensing
committee and they decided one o'clock
was the appropriate time and not 2300
hours
and I would assume that would be correct
I tend to agree with you Katherine I
think you are sick - right that that is
my conflict and that's why I'm just
trying to clarify the particular point
the licensing program process is
separate the planning application advice
was building surely the planning should
have been set up for approval before we
went for a license and this problem
would not have come about well it does
not for us to decide that is for the
applicant to decide there's no
legislative requirement for right
members can I just say something check
the gates at the moment the
recommendation in relation to the
section 106 is to agree a plan for the
opening and closing of the gates we
could involve the fire service in the
formulation of that plan just to make
sure they're happy with what Evers
agreed with that particular suggestion
thank you very much indeed because I
think that's essential and they would
also identified lighting I assume as
well for egress in the event of an
emergency of water but I assume okay
right
I'm still concerned about this
environment I was time I mean I'll as a
planning authority or planning committee
overriding what the licensing Committee
have already decided to one o'clock and
not taking the advice of the
Environmental Health Officer well I
think this is the debate but I'm willing
to put that to debate at the moment and
we can completely discuss that ourselves
Casavant appropriate John but I think we
should you know put this up to be sorted
out and then come back to the committee
yeah that's my personal opinion is that
a proposal council investigation
calibrates I'm sorry about this if mr.
Jeffrey states that we override the
licensing committee then I should be
happy not to defer we have the four
comments of the environment health
office
you also have the ability to disagree
and
yes I'm going to debate okay I'm going
to throw my temp anything on this bum
then I've got to say that I'm a little
I'm confused but for a different reason
perhaps we are talking about a bar and
yes I agree it is a not market bar is a
bar with controls and they were the
standard controls including if it's a
late opening past 12 o'clock you have a
doorman etc I accept because we can only
accept what the applicant is saying is
that it is a more upmarket bar for that
and I'm happy with that - really
intuitive though we have two pubs next
door to this very very close almost
adjacent but do have a license and they
were significantly more people attending
and to one o'clock in the morning my
concern is why are we actually the
constraining this particular license
given those conditions now the member
has suggested that because of the the
noise and suchlike again I suppose this
is subject to thing at the moment we
can't determine what the noise will be
but that is environmental health if they
are transgressing the rules of their
license and this is the problem won't
come from so I think that there's a
definite conflict between the licensing
permission granted and the planning now
at the end of the day we are looking at
of use the licensing committee have
actually assessed this on a drinks
license for a bar therefore perhaps they
are the ones who we should be looking at
to confirm what the hours of operation
should be now that's where I'm coming
from at the moment and I'm that's why
I'm confused on this particular point
there's too many proposals in a number
of how many people are outside various
things that did come up with the license
of another pub which were put through
and I feel that it needs addressing
before we we need all the facts I'm
happy to take this proposal but I just
like to clarify a few things you
mentioned about people without side well
that is specified at 10 you mentioned
about the fire brigade but apparently
they were aware of it but we can also
include a section 106 is that create a
section 106 agreement that they will
have to inspect it and agreed prior to
the bar opening so that's that
particular item is there anything else
that you wanted to propose in a
situation you've just been to two or
three things that you maybe all may be
able to address that's why I'm concerned
okay
council prank chairman as I said there's
only one element that we odds with and
that is a time of 2300 or 1 o'clock that
the license in panel agreed I think we
can determine this application and
decide if we want 2300 hours or one
o'clock that the licensing committee
have decided already and I can see mr.
Jeffery nodding it said in the
what I'm saying okay fine
any others I think all I wanted to add
was that I understand exactly where
counselor fragile II is coming from
she's made some very valid points but I
feel more comfortable knowing that we
can deal with the far aspect in terms of
exiting the site through closer look at
this section 106 agreement and in close
liaison with the fire safety team but in
but in my view I think that as I say I
think we it the licensing people are the
experts on licensing bars in the town we
are plant we are here as planning
experts thank you right now I have a
proposal hold on a second do I have a
second of accounts of bonds cancer
fielding okay we have a substantive
proposal the proposal is to defer the
item until we have more information and
we are talking about the Fire Rescue
Service including I assume CCTV and
lighting and egress in the event of an
emergency and you did also mention about
the number of people outside but like I
said that is that is a defined number do
you want to still continue that okay all
right
so members the vote before you is to
defer this item for further work by the
officers all those in favor all those
against
thank you that tables thank you
now then I do have a proposal Casa brain
I hear the concerns of the objectors on
that and they will know that the license
in the department can look at any
license and application have it referred
back to him if he doesn't work properly
so my proposal is to accept the officers
recommend
nation and condition 3 - change - 1 a.m.
and 12:00 o'clock Asst stated already
that the licensing committee decided
previously thank you doctor seconder for
that and before we carry on the we did
talk about the section 106 agreement the
additional one which will be the fire
and rescue service to assess the egress
is that you're happy will that to be
included are you I'm happy to second it
because I do believe that it's the
licensing people who are the experts in
this particularly thank you
members we have a proposal we have a
second that the vote before you is to
grant planning permission for 17 such a
double 203 sorry Ally for 17-0 three
five nine five size 4 with the
additional section 106 agreements which
I will ask David just to read those out
so we got clarity on that one please so
it's a six agreement thank you yes all
those in favor for chairman all those
against abstain to abstention the
application is granted per minute and
link plane commissioned this granted to
section 106 17 such oh three five nine
five such for granted to the section 106
agreements which you described thank you
right our next item on the agenda is 17s
- Oh double - Oh 3/4 Kings meat farm and
is the presenting officer
I listen are you ready
Thank You mr. chairman the application
site is located to the south of
chocolate denoted by the black dot it's
an open countryside approximately one
and a half miles from wells borne
chocolate is not an LS V the site is
near but not in chocolate and Hampton
Lucie Conservation Area here is an
aerial view of the site showing the
existing buildings outlined in red the
land bounds the grounds of chocolate
Park which is a hysto is a great to
start registered Historic Park and it
was farmed for many years as part of
that estate there is only one
neighboring property copper Heath which
is separated from the site by a high
fence and it has his own access
Kingsmead farm is an early 18th century
farmhouse with an extensive range of
19th century buildings grouped around a
courtyard located to the south of child
code none of the buildings are listed
but our assess is having entrance
intrinsic heritage value as an example
of a traditional Warwickshire farmstead
with a traditional layout and
traditional character to assist in the
explanation of the proposals the site
has been divided into four general areas
the existing farmhouse
is outlined in yellow the adjoining
bonds are outlined in green the stables
are right outlined in red and the
threshing barn is outlined in blue
the proposal now seeks approval for the
following building seven on the current
plan which is plot five outlined in
yellow is an extension and alteration of
the existing farmhouse to create one
four bedroom dwelling plot six and seven
buildings seven eight and nine on the
current plan outlined in green the
conversion extension and alteration to
create two three-bedroom dwellings plots
two three and four which are buildings
two three four five and six on the
current plan are outlined in red the
proposal is for the removal of the
holiday holiday light restriction and
reconfiguration of the accommodation to
create one four bedroom dwelling which
would be plot for and two two-bedroom
dwellings which will be plots two and
three
plot one which is building one on the
current plan which is outlined in blue
towards the bottom of the page is the
conversion of a former threatened bond
to create a one to create one
four-bedroom dwelling building eleven on
the current plan which is outlined in
orange on the extreme right hand side is
conversion into a garage or garage and I
should say what one has a new double
garage proposed to be sited adjacent to
the threshing barn
there's two more garage blocks plot
blocks four plots six and seven outlined
in purple and a garage block for visitor
parking and next to building 11 the
application also proposes hard both hard
and soft landscaping
there is quite a long and complex
history to the site but notably the site
has the following extant permissions
there is consent to convert building
seven eight and nine into three
residential units there is consent to
convert building one which is a
threshing barn on plot one into two
residential dwellings and buildings two
three four five and six which cover
plots two three and four are currently
in use as holiday let's so turning to
the farmhouse initially this slide shows
the comparison between the existing
farmhouse and the proposed rear
extensions that ground and first of all
to create a one-bedroom dwelling so you
can see the large rear extensions on the
new proposals
this slide shows elevations of the
existing farmhouse on the left of the
picture and the comparison with the
proposed altered elevations and the
proposed extensions at ground and first
floor so the top picture is the front
elevation second row is the rear
elevation and then the west and east
elevations at the sides
so this slide illustrates the rear
elevation of the farmhouse and the bomb
as compared to the proposals and the
previously consented more modest scheme
at the bottom
so this slide shows the previously
approved floorplan of the barn that
ground floor and first floor as compared
to the proposals with larger rear
extensions to both floors
this slide shows the changes to the
roofline to the stable building over
this building here
and this slide shows the proposed
changes to the front and rear elevations
of the stables showing more modern
treatment and glazing
so this is a threshing barn which if you
recall was on the bottom of the initial
slide so this photo shows the existing
threshing bran and the proposals and the
previously consented scheme and the
different different treatments so by way
of illustration of the site
I've got a few slides showing the site
as it is now so this is the farmhouse
the original farmhouse on the left of
the picture with the adjacent barn with
chimneys fairly fairly traditional
layout illustration that's the side of
the existing farmhouse that's the rear
of the existing farmhouse and the rear
of the threshing barn next door to it
showing a variety of existing current
extensions that's the front of the
threshing barn looking out onto the
courtyard
that's the side of side of the
agricultural barns which is going to be
converted into a car barn so where you
see those windows that's going to be
techno confronted that's what's been
referred to as the stables building or
part of the stables building that's the
slightly further along rear of the
stables building that's another view of
the stables building that's the internal
courtyard with the original the other
threshing barn to the left and the
stables facing yeah yep and that's the
threshing barn which was on plot of one
that's the other side of the same
threshing barn
so mr. chairman there is there was one
update as detailed on the update sheet
and the recommendation is to refuse the
application for the reasons detailed in
the report thank you our first speaker
is mr. Peter Jenkins
good evening Peter you have three
minutes press the button at the bottom
obviously done this particular wall
before speak clearly into the microphone
don't get too close okay apparently you
haven't a presentation could you
indicate to the officers when you want
them to change slides thank you good
evening my name is Peter Jenkins I'm one
of the directors at studio spies they're
architects thank you all for taking the
time to consider our application this
evening particularly given what a
beautiful summer evening is the
application is here because the offices
recommended refusal that the board
member and the parish both support the
application all three reasons for
refusal in essence can be more simply
expressed as the officers opinion on
design and the impact it has on the
existing buildings the landscape and the
setting of the conservation area and
Charcot Park as experienced architects
dealing with heritage issues on the
majority of our projects we have
developed these proposals with the
primary aim of restoring and enhancing
the existing buildings on site and the
wider setting as such no benefits are
required to outweigh harm here we
consider that there is no harm and there
are in fact we are proposing significant
enhancement at every level at the
detailed level we are refurbishing and
restoring everything that is historic
about the existing buildings we are
reusing existing openings and inserting
traditional timber-framed multi-pane
windows in them our proposals will also
restore existing brick work repairing
significantly dilapidated structures so
that they're brought back to life this
is the most sustainable option in both
environmental and historic terms we're
also proposing to reuse the Dutch barn
as a single undivided dwelling rather
than the brutally subdivided approach
taken by the extant permission for the
conversion at the medium scale we're
proposing some extension and adaptation
around the site but in a manner that
improves
on the extant permissions for the site
if you've got a slide one up there so
that's the extant permission for the
extensions if you care about to slide
one thank you
that's the extant permission for the
extensions to the balance and then if
you go to slide two you'll see the
extensions bit we're proposing if you go
back to slide one just briefly as you
can see it converts the buildings and
extends them deep into the site more
significantly bringing a fresh access
across Greenfield forming a new
roundabout and car park on what would be
the frontage facing child cut Park which
is just to the north of that site it's
noted that the case officer in a report
does not appear to give any weight to
this or any of the other extant
permissions in her report we consider
this fallback position is a serious
material consideration appears to have
been overlooked on slide three you can
see our proposals in comparison direct
comparison with the extant permission
you can go to three by comparison our
extensions are more reflective of the
linear nature of these are some
structures have impact gardens that face
the park creating space and a greener
interface between the two in direct
comparison the enhancement of our
proposals becomes more clear in slide
four for more clarity we've prepared
visualizations comparing the existing at
the top the prepared the extant
permission the second one down and our
proposals the third one down on slide at
the wider scale first of all we're
proposing to bring this site back into a
sustainable use if you get is live five
as you can see from the existing access
its own counting could be enhanced with
proper landscape management in addition
the South boundaries ask you to wrap up
a little bit with the slides but so
we're enhancing the landscape we were
enhancing the boundaries we're taking
down conifer trees in putting
native trees in and new hedging and
fencing which is what the locals have
asked for we think there's opportunities
here to secure a high-quality
restoration of historic structures
alongside high quality new additions
designed to be of their own time but
respectful to the context with
channel 4 but high quality materials I
hope that you'll be able to support
application and approval this evening
thank you thank you very much it's the
representation from the parish council
support hasn't been uploaded as far as
I'm aware but we have received
notification of their support I don't
know why it's not been made public
okay well you can just regard that
comment yes I just wonder whether you
can explain why the previous permissions
um
I've just been let go they all - yes so
they haven't been let go they've
actually begun to enact much of them but
then they've realized there's a
viability assessment that comes along
with this application that as a whole it
doesn't restock up and they're looking
to create a higher quality development
which is why they brought us on board to
look at this scheme holistically rather
than as lots of individual parts and try
and bring it together as born high
quality development supplementary can
you advise whether any any liaison with
the parish was done in terms of local
housing need and within the parish
because obviously in terms of current
SDC policy so in terms of local housing
need not specifically there was liaison
with the parish council and as I said I
understood we'd gone at their support
however the the types of housing
proposed in terms of the number of
dwellings is more informed by the
existing structures than specifically by
housing need so we're trying to work
with the existing structures not
subdividing them arbitrarily in the way
the extant permissions do so if it's a
big barn it remains a big barn which is
good design if it's a small van it
remains a small van you mentioned
you feel that there is no harm in the
the sense of the could you just explain
that again so the officers report
suggests that there is harm to the
setting of the conservation area and of
the great to solicited park of child cut
we couldn't see that the concept any
conservation officer had been consulted
in the report it was the officers own
opinion
we don't think bearing in mind the
episode permissions in particular and
the state of the existing buildings that
what we're proposing is harmful we think
that it is an enhancement so it's a
difference of opinion on whether or not
harm exists here if there is no harm
then you don't need benefits to outweigh
that huh I noticed on page 57 highway
matters that the requirement from the
draft parking standards higher than that
the parking proposed at the moment have
you taken anything to do with a draft
parking standards or can you alter your
parking area to meet those requirements
the the parking in terms of per dwelling
may be below the draft standards but it
should be noted that they are draft and
they have limited weight but there is
additional parking for visitors also we
feel that it's enough parking for a
development of this size
in the conservation area you understand
the farmhouse has got an extension
whatever yeah
if you get go back to the site plan
sorry so the farmhouse is the top left
property there that is that the
extension on the back of that is facing
chocolate Park to the north so with what
the projects done permission has a long
extension into that back garden but it
actually becomes its frontage with a car
park at the front of it and a roundabout
our proposal is to make that the back
garden so the space and greenery between
the two so if you go to the extant
permission which is the slide just
before this the top left there you see
that there the extant permission
proposes an extension deep into the site
with a roundabout which you can see just
to the right hand side of the extension
you can see that where there's cars
shown turning so that's that would be
the frontage that you'd get facing child
cut Park with the extant permission with
our proposals it's back garden green
space with shorter extensions that don't
extend as far into that green space
right any other questions ok thank you
very much
right remembers technical questions Oh
before we go into that I have a
statement well the council Richards has
provided a his views on this so I shall
now read this out on his behalf right
members the decision for this
application appears to hinge on two main
factors the appropriate conversion by
way of scale and division of the
existing buildings the impact on the
conservation area by way of scale design
and appearance the case officer rightly
points out in their report that our
policies as ten CS 15 + CS 20 all allow
for the conversion of existing buildings
and indeed this site has the benefit a
previously approved
and extant planning permission to
convert the existing buildings into
separate dwellings so the principle of
conversion on this site exists and being
extant
there is very a clear very clear
fallback position the question then is
really is the proposed a better option
than that of the extant looking at the
scale of the buildings first the
existing building total 1449 meter
squared in size where the extant
Commission seeks to increase that to
1577 this proposal however seeks to
reduce the overall footprint where total
size of the converted buildings would be
one thousand four hundred and fifty
seven meter squared significant
reduction in scale and both from the
size from both the existing and extant
permission
therefore the concern over size and
scale is overcome that then leaves us
for the decision based on the design and
appearance of the proposed design is as
you know subjective one person's good
design does not always accord with
another personally I consider the
designers buildings to be a high quality
and one that would complement the
surrounding area in particular it is
particular portman important to note the
Dutch barn conversion directly opposite
this site which is of a considerably
more modern style that moves far away
from what one would expect in a rural
location yet it was granted the proposed
is a modernization of existing buildings
but one that even case officer states on
page 55 when referring to plot want to
be more sympathetic significant weight
also appears to being given to the
impact of the buildings and in
particular their design would have on
the heritage asset of Charcot Park
Charcot Park is a National Trust
property who do in fact support this
application as it would enhance the
views from their site overall the
proposed is seeking to bring back into
use a series of dilapidated and unused
barns and buildings that are in
desperate need of love and attention
this is a wonderful scheme that is in
keeping with the area as aborted by
myself
and the parish council I would encourage
you to support this proposal for the
reasons I have given if how are we are
still to be convinced I would encourage
a deferment for site visit so that you
can fully appreciate the location of the
proposed and the minor impact it would
have on the wider area end of statement
so now we can move to questions of the
Confessor I mean so we mentioned both by
the agent and in your statement you just
read out the council there's got support
from chocolate from the parish council
documentation were the trust consulted
yes both Parish Council and the National
Trust have been consulted on the
original application and subsequent
amendments the National Trust I have not
heard anything from the National Trust
at all nor the parish council and parish
council in their first submission said
no objection and then I had never had
any further responses to any of the
following consultations thank you that
was one of my questions although any
heritage objections but right any other
questions
but he did say just to clarify he didn't
actually say he wanted though he said if
you are still too convinced already
encourage a deferment for a site visit
so he's not saying no nothing saying if
you're not convinced about it right any
other technical questions
climbing history Jerry I just thought it
would be relevant to mention in respect
of the planning history that's been put
before members in the agenda and by the
applicant a number of those permissions
which may still be expandable granted
policy which has changed thank you
all right I shall then open it up for
debate let's say I go along with
councilor Richards comments it makes
good use of buildings I must say there
are some very nice windows which I would
dead against losing as being entrances
to a carport that whole car garage
whatever you call it but apart from that
calamari cousin Thank You chair this is
a difficult one because we have previous
permissions under a previous policy
we've all worked extremely hard to
develop policy for our core strategy
which has been in place now for two
years there are a lot of this is not
even a village it's not even an LS v4
village one of the lowest villages where
the only way we can get development
through a we certainly can't get it in
open countryside B we have to have
serious local need there has been no
undertaking by the parish in terms of
what the parish council needs I would
have more sympathy for this application
if there had been more done to support
the current policy there is no legal
none of these units have been I
identified his local need and I think
it's a great shame that the ward member
who has gone out to support this
unfortunately isn't here for us to ask
pertinent questions neither is the
parish council who we are led to believe
support this and therefore on this
occasion in order to support SDC's core
strategy and all the villages and all
the other areas where we have had
similar sort of applications come for I
have to support the officers
recommendation for refusal which concern
was the book the question twice that
there isn't going to be any major
concern against the fully concur both
camps up area so I don't go all over
them again planning policy has changed I
think the reasons for refusal are very
strong I would have liked to have seen
councillor Richards here to give us his
story what I know and what I've heard
recommendation that's the second in a
proposal from notes for Barry I'm happy
to do so thank you very much this is a
tricky one and I must admit it looking
at the photographs especially and the
drawings I I don't personally believe
that it will be as impactful as perhaps
even the extant permission I however do
agree that it is
now contrary to our core strategy right
let's take those things in to account
the the it would be lovely to see this
site and developed they are large
buildings they're very large buildings
and I think some of the issues that the
officer has is retaining some of the
architectural features of the old
threshing barn etc and I feel perhaps
more can be done there I've seen a
number of barn conversions in this
district where that particular for
example door has been retained to
demonstrate it was a barn in the
fleshing bomb I get that one the
fenestration I'm not too convinced about
but one thing it does do it shows the
difference in design change so it it
does comply with that sort of policy
where it's not the Custis of the
existing which I think in fairness the
extant permission would probably be a
little bit more the downside of that of
course is if you lose out lovely red
brick the workshop went brick
and that was a shame in that particular
context
I am very balanced on this one very
balanced however I I will say that I
have to go with Council Perry on this
one and say that I mean I will go with
the opposite I think it's finely
balanced I really hope that this is
brought back with the relevant amendment
so that it can be brought forward as a
schema because I would be very quite
happy to support it before I stop
talking and you'll see Cheers
I would ask whether anyone should take
up the offer of counselor riches to
defer this for a site inspection Council
fielding
every useful to have a site meeting even
if they're going to bring it back at
least we get a feel of what what's there
and what needs to be done I think there
are two things there first things first
I do have a pose and a seconder for
refusal as per the officers and if you
wish to change that to a deferral that
you're happy to still go for refusal I'm
happy to propose sorry
refusal sorry Calipari is to whose
encounter brain is seconding it on that
particular point well let us take that
that on first members the vote before
you for 1700 to 203 such for Kingsmead
farm is to refuse plank permission all
those in favor against against okay
casting votes of the Chairman thank you
very much as I did vote in support of
the officers recommendation I will
retain that so this committee therefore
resolves to refuse prime commissions of
17 - OH - - Oh 3/4 thank you and I
expect that if it is brought back it
would be a slight visit would be
requested okay thank you is there any
other urgent business
our therefore close the meeting thank
you